[Musica]
buonasera a tutti e tutti buonasera un
ben trovati come va bene mi sembra
abbastanza bene
tema di questa sera rigenerazione mi
piace molto è una bella parola e nel
lazio
c'era eccetera eccetera rigenerazione e
bella sulla nota ha solo dato cercarmi
il significato preciso sul vocabolario
io sono un signore di mezza età perciò
quando ero giovane onda molari
intendevano insieme alle enciclopedie
bussando sci a casa oppure suonando il
campanello oggi invece per andarlo a
cercare il significato sul porno volare
non è bastato aprire
l'internet e perciò l'ho trovato e dice
il ristabilirsi di un integrità
strutturale o fisiologica in tessuti
organi o parti del corpo precedentemente
perduti può asportati anche un altro
significato la parola rigenerazione ed è
la restituzione o il recupero di uno
stato di grazia o di dignità morale
sociale politica è davvero bello cioè
proprio figlio a best young direbbero
soliti giovini di appena un'era
geologica fa prima di me
dunque questa è la rigenerazione che di
solito finisce bene perché altrimenti
non sarebbe rigenerato ecco io vi
parlerò prevalentemente di ge
rigenerazioni in itinere in cui la
questione non è ancora completata rimane
tutt'oggi molto compressa ci sono parti
del tessuto che ancora non sono
ricresciute è una rigenerazione in cui
l'umanità ancora molto da fare di questo
vi voglio parlare perché le
rigenerazioni naturali sono complicate
ma alla fine sono appunto naturali cioè
il tessuto neri cresce noi non ci si
deve fare in realtà niente le ossa che
si attaccano bisogna stare attenti
ovviamente a non dargli delle botte
delle bottarelle durante ma poi si
riassestano da sole se uno le mette in
posizione giusta e aspetta prima magari
di ridarci un cazzottone sopra poi ci
sono invece quelle rigenerazione umane
che dipendono completamente e totalmente
da noi ecco quelle sono più complicate
ed è di quelle che in parte fare meglio
provare a parlarvi e allora uno dice a
questo punto va bene sapere o nei tre
minuti tu parli a questo punto parlaci
di queste nuove rigenerazione e ve ne
parlo non ve l'ho promesso un qui
apposta ecco non sarei venuto se non ve
ne avessi voluto parlare torna il verbo
si non sarei venuto se non ve ne avessi
voluto parlare ma speriamo di si sa se
no che figura di merda sbagliare un
verbo un congiuntivo alte lexington ma
credo di averla giocata o forse no se
italia e dunque allora ve ne parlo in
queste rigenerazioni successive ancora
più complicate delle altre
shipper ship
all'inglese perché non si parla anche
inglese
shp ho scoperto che si pronuncia con la
allungata shift altrimenti sarebbe
economo di basso e poco prezzo
chi invece vuol dire lo sapete
che vuol dire scelto vuol dire pecora
vengono vuol dire ship ed è il nome
dell'associazione che ora ideato ed in
cui sono oggi presidente è
un'associazione che prova ad avere cura
degli inciampi non li nega perché
sarebbe proprio come si dice dalle mie
credo anche dalle vostre parti pretesi
da bischeri regale gli inciampi che
fanno parte del cammino non si riesce a
progredire non si riesce ad andare
avanti senza inciampare ed incespicare
però il tempo stesso un certo punto
bisogna provare a rialzarsi non sempre
facile non tutti ce la fanno non tutti
sono nelle condizioni adatte sempre per
provare a rialzarsi per questo ecco
capua che interviene shift super prova a
rigenerare attraverso i sentimenti
l'insegnamento del lavoro a maglia ho
indossato anche questa maglietta che è
sostanzialmente il logo della nostra
associazione e che facciamo insomma
facciamo questa roba strana di insegnare
a lavorare a maglia a gruppi di persone
in particolare con una fragilità con una
vulnerabilità addosso e intorno
in particolare lavoriamo in questo
momento con quattro gruppi hanno a che
vedere con la salute mentale
questa questione complicata difficile
premia di pregiudizio e anche con donne
rifugiate
spesso vittime di tratta perciò andiamo
queste situazioni insegniamo a lavorare
a maglia perché il lavoro a maglia
riesce a
rigenerare le persone attraverso
l'insegnamento di qualcosa che riescono
a fare con le mani qualcosa che possono
tenere per sé e che possono regalare
agli altri regalare agli altri e la
pratica del dono e ciò che rigenera
maggiormente dal punto di vista umano
può essere un cappello può essere un
maggiore può essere comunque qualcosa di
caldo e di colorato qualcosa che fa
crescere i fiori dove prima invece
prevaleva l'insicurezza è certa
sterpaglia elettiva facciamo con le
nostre volontari lo facciamo con un
educatrice professionale che prova a
raccordare animo e animi
questo sempre serve per gli animi sver
tacciati come tutti è nel senso non è
che soltanto le persone che hanno una
questione aperta con la salute mentale
donne rifugiate i sogni e le sole
abbiano dell'inciampo ma ce l'abbiamo
tutti e loro sono se mi vedete
sostanzialmente persone personaggi
normali ho visto nessuno mai con le
corna che fa parte dei nostri gruppi
almeno non con corna visibili nessuno
con la coda davvero giuro non ho mai
c'era mai nessuno collaborava o comunque
se la sono nascosta bene però mi sembra
che cominciassero la coda erano di di
vari colori le persone partecipano ai
nostri gruppi rosa pallido marroncino
giallino sbiadito però ad esempio non
c'era nessuno verde ecco anche per
questo dico che è gente normale ho mai
visto nessuno verde con le antenne ecco
le antenne non ho mai visto nessuno
partecipare ai nostri gruppi quali
soppressori normale che però hanno avuto
qualche problema con l'impoverimento e
l'impoverimento nella questione è un
problema in effetti grosso in cui è
possibile incappare ma non lo facciamo
perché san buono insomma non ci
occupiamo delle fragilità perché siamo
gente buona
anzi non siamo buoni per un cazzo noi ci
piace neanche moltissimo l'aggettivo
qualificativo buono preferiamo provare
ogni tanto a incappare nella giustizia
cioè nell'essere giusto ecco questo ci
il viaggio di più accarezzare le
fragilità erano sempre ovviamente ci
riesce ma noi ci si trova anche ma nel
faticoso anche quando le ascelle surer o
come tipo ora se volete vedere le
mascelle sudate immagino tutti di sì per
ciotto ecco per fortuna ho portato la
maglia blu scuro perciò non si vede lo
vedrete un'altra un'altra meravigliosa
questione che di su cui uscita mi aiuta
a non far vedere le ascelle giurate
lasciamo stare cieli scusa usata
su come mezz'ora anche maremma impestata
sulle celle sudate e
allora facciamo questo insegniamo a
lavorare a maglia persone normali e poi
siccome però
in fondo nessuno di noi è normale ci
siamo inventati anche una cosa cioè ad
autunno scorso cioè ad uno 2020 abbiamo
chiesto di mandarci di spedirci dei
quadratini di lana di 15 cm x 15 cm che
poi noi avremmo trasformato in coperte e
avremmo distribuito persone senza dimora
cioè senza casa non senza fissa dimora
perché se volete sapere se tu non ce la
fa da qualche parte invece la provincia
intende vive fuori all'aperto senza
dimora alcuna al freddo al ghiaccio è
difficile pensare questa cosa perché ora
siamo a luglio io sto sudando ve l'ho
già detto avere questa rosa delle
ascelle però d'inverno fa davvero freddo
cioè c'è la gente che muore per il
freddo tutti gli anni tutti gli inverni
perciò anche la questione dell'emergenza
freddo è è un abitante cioè non c'è
nessuna emergenza freddo perché
l'emergenza improvvisa se ora miss
allagasse la casa dei miei genitori dove
sono venuto perché la missione migliore
ecco questa sala e di una emergenza
nessuno se l'aspetta però che d inverno
faccia freddo e che fuori patisca il
freddo qualcuno anche fino a morirci non
dovrebbe essere considerata un'emergenza
ma una questione di naturalezza grimana
in realtà tutti gli inverni ci troviamo
in qualcuno fuori
rientra così tanto trento dentro che non
riesce a rialzarsi la mattina e allora
noi quest'anno grazie a questi
quadratini di lara ci sono arrivati da
tutta italia ed altri 8 paesi europei ed
extra europei siamo riusciti a
realizzare
587 coperte di lana colorata nuove
morbide e poi abbiamo distribuito a
queste persone coperte per cui il tempo
di lavoro è lungo c'era gente ci diceva
lei
c'è gente su internet quando ci
raccontava vedere delle foto ci sia le
posso comprare perché davvero hanno un
valore questi coperte noi vogliamo dare
a loro alle persone fuori delle degli
oggetti che possono scaldare dal punto
di vista fisico ma anche da un punto di
vista emotivo cioè queste ore con un
valore il valore valore è una questione
una parola e ci piace parecchio
parecchio e di molto e dunque potremo
anche scegliere i colori perché la
bellezza la rigenerazione delle persone
umana deve essere espansa e allora
quando facciamo scegliere il colore
delle coperte a queste persone tornano
fuori quasi sempre non sono interessate
ci dicono no non importa sceglie il
colore non coperta ma bene grazie no il
colore no e poi questo con accenti mari
ma negate meravigliosi no non importa
non fare scegliere coloro non importa
dammi qualche aiuole ed ai croce e noi
lo scellino invece colori scegliere il
colore importante porta alla
rigenerazione
si tratta prevalentemente di persone che
hanno scelto poco pochissimo
negli ultimi anni delle loro vite delle
loro esistenze non hanno scelto neanche
l'orario in cui mangiare perché mangiano
quando qualcuno e me lo faccio e questo
qualcuno li porta da mangiare non
scelgono il menu nemmeno cosa mangiare
scelgono mentre tutti noi possiamo
scegliere ad esempio cosa mangiare e
cosa vi basta sera dopo il telex e uno
decide se si fa gli spaghetti se va a
mangiare giapponese oppure oppure me c'è
una pizza loro nonno scelgono nemmeno
questo non scelgono mete stir sì perché
non hanno un'arma da cui poter scegliere
allora almeno il colore della coperta si
e questo crea delle relazioni con queste
persone meravigliose
c'è sempre poi era certo punto la si sa
che spunta la nonna qualcuno che jacques
uscito e ha lavorato a maglia perché
tutti da qualsiasi parte del mondo una
vera hanno una conoscenza che lavorava o
amalia comunque appunto usciva e questo
è il gancio per iniziare a parlare ci si
rigenera non c'è non c'è un'altra
possibilità
le parole hanno questi importanza qui mi
ricordo due storie queste due storie del
racconto è quella di orlando orlando la
casa celava in realtà abita a roma però
è una casa senza nemmeno le finestre
perché sono tutte rotte non c'è soldi
per accomodare e non c'è il
riscaldamento ovviamente perché non
aveva i soldi per pagarle l'anno non
democraticamente staccato che possa
sopravvivere solo gli ha più soldi
talvolta non è solo l'idea di un dito
puntato è che purtroppo è davvero così
ed è davvero indegno dunque orlando
prese due coperti una persona per la sua
mamma 94 anni che viveva con lui in
questa casa senza riscaldamento con le
finestre sfondate eccetera eccetera
eccetera e ora lo si prendeva cura si
prende tutto ora cura della sua mamma
urlando che a vederlo mi sono domandato
ne faccia prendersi cura della sua ma
perché non sa che orlando sia
particolarmente bene però lo ha detto
che più volte al giorno o comunque
quando ce n'è bisogno si prende cura e
la somma la lava e la porta anche in
giro c'è proprio la prende in braccio
scendono le scale e la porta a fare una
giratina e gli ho detto orlando l'anno e
perché la prende in braccio per si tuffa
le scarpe delle scale ma prende
l'ascensore e lui mi ha detto
l'ascensione non c'è
questo per dire che ce l'ha capita forse
a me più che ad altri di fare domande
imbecilli perciò non hanno
washington hanno riscaldamento non sanno
nulla o pochissimo compreso il venerato
gli abbiamo dato anch'io
come lui davvero a 587 persone
prossimale o replicheremo infatti
invitiamo tutte ma da ci potrete milan
ha qualche mano belli colorati nuovi non
ci mandate roba piena di gente da noi
siamo delle ceche non importa anche nel
leggere la lama o
questa per me e rigenerazione provare a
stabilire delle questioni o le persone e
ha molto a che vedere con il sognare il
sognare l'altro verbo a cui io voglio
molto bene oltre al sostantivo
rigenerare credo sognare sia sia la
sorella il fratello queste parole un
giovane maschile e del femminile nella
attualità delle questioni del rigenerare
e allora c'è una citazione sul sognare
che vi voglio dire in realtà e
un'autocitazione
vergogno un po perché la fucilazione
sono bruttissime realtà non è vero mi
vergogno ne frega proprio nulla mi piace
la frase sul sognare e ve la dico
ed è questa sognare che è come
rigenerare è un atto di insubordinazione
collettiva un modo divertente per
sabotare la banalità e questo è da me
ultimo libro in fondo basta una parola
che sono pubblicitario basta
e questo credo sia importante per
provare a cambiare cioè sognare sognare
perché non esiste nessuna rigenerazione
che prima non sia stato ha sognato anche
queste una bella frase ci sono queste
frasi provo a portarmi nello zainetto
invisibile e tengo dietro le spalle e
quando ne ho l'occasione la possibilità
vivace da ex migrato provo a condividere
con chi mi sta di fronte anche se
dall'altra parte di un computer e allora
vi racconto anche quest'altra cosa e poi
sicura a proposito della rigenerazione
che riguarda anche il mio lavoro cioè le
storie che racconto cip cip è un costo
di tempo un costo enorme dal punto di
vista economico un guadagno enorme dal
punto di vista umano però non è il mio
lavoro quel mestiere per cui son pagato
quello per cui sono pagato e fare il
giornalista lo scrittore e giornalista
alla fine amerina spesso in mano che
però qui ma che io chiamo la mia 1500
punto perché quanto la pagaia otto anni
fa e vado con quella raccontare le
storie e una storia di rigenerazione non
compiuta totalmente ancora da vivere e
quella dei campi rom ce n'è uno a 200
metri da casa mia e quella è una
rigenerazione da compiere spesso si
associano sentano associare dagli
avventori dei bar anche i bar non fisici
alla parola sgombero ma sgomberare che
mando vanno intesi bilità abbattuta
picchiata alla disperazione quotidiana e
la vorreste anche mandare fuori da quel
rimasuglio di terreno di di terra di
baraccopoli in anno ecco per me in quel
caso invece bisogna provare a puntare
anche se molto creato lo so bisogna
iniziare su una rigenerazione è fatta
dai fulmini che passano a prendere i
bambini e le bambine per andare a scuola
permettendo loro di arrivarci a scuola
se non ci hanno nemmeno macchina e se il
nome trial giorno i bambini possono fare
avanti e indietro e poi anche una
rigenerazione di alloggi ecco vorrei
partire da dagli estremi perché mi
cacciano gli estremi gli estremismi cioè
sono sono estremi bambini e
rivoluzionari e per questo infatti sono
così simili perché provano a sognare
forte e a occhi aperti
e allora faccio gli auguri a tutte e
tutti voi a me stesso mi faccia divina
di mina compie gli anni a gennaio come
me fino ai due anni più piccina di me ha
40 anni e meno 42 e quando la incontrai
avevo questa coperta in mano a milano
lei disse mi voglio fare un regalo per
il mio compleanno disse vi voglio
regalare l'entrata in comunità però fra
il dire riuscire ci sono spesso le
mancate di generazioni e allora di dire
as alzarono gli occhi al cielo gli
effetti delle droghe pesanti e stava per
cadere dalle scale un altro che erano
lei a dormì fuori le urlò di nina jesi a
lei riuscì a un certo punto ad a
reggersi almeno in quell'occasione per
quella frazione ecco il mio augurio è di
riuscire a trovare ognuna e ognuno di
noi una rigenerazione cioè qualcuno che
ci dia la mano e che ci faccia da
ringhiera nei momenti difficili che è
quello che proviamo a fare uno scipp e
quello e proviamo a fare ogni giorno
anche incespicando ma per andare avanti
non c'è un'altra possibilità grazie a
tutte ea tutti vi voglio bene un sacco e
un monte